the amount of memes and things that
people have made that they are so
creative we've all just been loving it
and laughing
paris we have not seen you since the
wedding you have that glow of love how
is newlywed life i am just loving it
he's just so kind and such an amazing
husband and
we're just so excited for our life
together in the future
now you stepped away for the night to
come celebrate with your family how much
fun is a night like this i always love
supporting my family and i'm so proud of
my brother baron and tessa for starting
their new company helping the states
group and just doing these beautiful
events and
yeah tonight looks amazing i'm actually
looking for houses with carter right now
so i went upstairs with the owner and i
was like i want to see the master let me
see the closets and it's a sick house
now house hunting with your husband what
are what are the things that you guys
need what's on the checklist
you know a gated community is something
that's really important to us just
because what i've went through in life
and like a recording studio a movie
theater we need a pool guest house
tennis court definitely because he loves
his tennis and just like a family house
so lots of room big closets
to fill with the growing family the
hiltons are growing yes we are now you
know newlywed life what would you say is
the best part for you always being
together just having your other half and
your best friend and i just don't even
like to go out anymore unless i have to
for work or something
um so it's nice just to be able to just
be at home and cook and have a normal
life and just enjoy
everything
that i've worked so hard for and now i
finally get to enjoy it with someone who
i really love and
trust as kim kardashian says the best is
being able to be at home and do nothing
with your love
exactly it's the best now we mentioned
your wedding another wedding that you
went to recently is of course britney's
don't just stand there let's get to it
strike a pose there's nothing to it what
do you make of the internet calling you
gals you selena drew madonna the
avengers so cute the amount of memes and
things that people have made they are so
creative
all these people online and we've all
just been loving it and laughing and
just thinking it's so fun and
it's really cute what was the highlight
of brit's wedding for you to see
everything just her walking down the
aisle and just seeing this the sparkle
in her eyes and
you know more than anyone she deserves
this happy ending and her freedom and it
just represented so much like it was
just
such a beautiful intimate affair and it
was unforgettable in a fairy tale and i
was just so proud to be there for her
you have been there every step of the
way for her it's really incredible to
see how amazing of a friend you are
well i love her so much she's an angel
and
i don't trust many people especially in
this town but she is one girl that has
always been there for me and always been
so kind and trustworthy and it's just so
sweet would never hurt a fly is like
just one of the kindest people i've ever
met in my life well as are you birds of
a feather flock together exactly we
stick together
now are you in carter do you guys have
cameras rolling for another season of
paris in love right now no
to see
stay tuned that's not a no you have been
so open about wanting to start that next
chapter of your life and talking about
ivf you know it's something that needs
to be talked about more how are you and
carter doing on your journey to
parenthood together
amazing we have
tons of eggs just waiting to
be brought into the world
so yeah we did that during the pandemics
was the perfect timing the world shut
down
and just having that time where i didn't
have to travel and and be everywhere
like usual so i'm so happy that we did
that and um we did that right away like
we knew right away we wanted to have a
family
so um i'm so happy that we did it now
next year marks 20 years since the
simple life in this age of reboots you
know someone's going to want us want to
do it what advice would you give them
going into a show like that just to have
fun you know when nicole and i did that
show there was nothing like it so
we were just we had no idea what we were
getting ourselves into but we just had
so much fun so my advice would be is to
do it with someone that you really love
who you want to spend time with someone
who's funny someone who's going to be
entertaining
and someone who just
is a good partner in crime and
just having a good time because
if anyone tries to do that but
there's you know a lot of people try to
copy but there's nothing like the
original no
nothing like the
ogs is there two people that you would
like have in mind maybe who could do it
lele pons would be really funny i love
her she's so sweet she's one of my
closest friends just to my podcast a
couple days ago
she's so funny and just does not give an
f
and will do anything so i think she
would be dope
[Music]
you